[Music]
hi I'm Michele Simmons quantum
physicists and Australian of the Year
I met master Jenny wound and this tray
today Awards recently where I was struck
by his passion for education and the
quick lesson he gave my three kids at
the ceremony Eddie first featured an
Australian story about a year ago and
since then his career has skyrocketed as
you'll see from tonight's story
Eddie's now in the running to be named
the world's best teacher the global
teacher prize went out as a call all
around the world and 30,000 people
entered and somehow I've been the top 10
I was stunned now he's flying to Dubai
we really can't believe it he's hardly
ever flown anywhere but he's done more
travel in the last few months than in
his entire life
I had to renew my passport because it
had expired that long ago and I've never
been to the continent let alone the city
I won't advise that's gonna be a whole
new experience the 12 months that I've
just been through my wife and I call it
the magic carpet ride very very suddenly
being thrust into the national spotlight
and people coming and talking to me and
saying I knew that teacher guy Haiti was
Australia's most famous teacher
everybody wants a part of him now
[Music]
we use the math teacher everyone would
have wanted to have and thanks to woo
tube you can have mr. woo as you messed
teacher decided to record his lessons
and he began posting online 12 months
ago he had four mean hits on his YouTube
website at the present moment it's over
12 mean just an extraordinary number
what's something you would feel
confident explaining in front of other
people there is a certain irony that
Eddy now spends less time with his
classes than he used to
laughs a real juggle now sometimes I
feel like I'm spinning all of these
plates and wondering which one's going
to fall life has shifted quite a lot for
me in terms of my work
the New South Wales Department of
Education has given me a new role that
allows me to move around and actually
work with teachers and students even in
some really remote and regional areas
it's very first time I've done something
like this I grabbed an 8:30 flight out
of Sydney dropped into Griffith Airport
around 10:00 in the beautiful New South
Wales River Rina
our principal contacted us yesterday and
said any wheezing town text back woohoo
if you want to go we're like it's about
500 kids from all over the region of
bust in he arrives with a profile he
arrives with a very excited enthusiastic
room before him
[Music]
I liken it to this generation is Julius
son Miller a charismatic teacher who
uses the latest technology to expand the
reach of his classroom far beyond the
students who are seated in front of him
I'd like you to imagine that you walk
out of the Griffith regional theater and
you meet an alien they come and they see
you and they grab you out and they say
hey you just went to this thing about
maths but on my planet we don't we don't
know what math is what is maths
what would you say yeah it's been a
great honor to be able to work with
primary schools high school teachers and
kids helping them understand mathematics
really is and helping them find their
patch of it
mathematics is played and that is a
story video and real offered two
different things so I reckon it's even
more intriguing hearing him in real life
they proved to us that maths can be fun
it's not always hard work it's not
always you know headaches number of
problems elgible I'm one of youth and
it's a great joy to be actually the flag
now that he just being there for his
twenty kids
he's now inspiring hundreds of teachers
so we can go back to our twenty kids yes
sorry it's just a ball on a fact yeah
I'm gonna take that hello
yeah I'm driving at the moment sorry I
am I got your text that I'm trying to
get to trying to get to Orgel Walker as
soon as I can
cuz it's a middle Hotei I'm kind of
tired
one of the hardest things about being
out here on the road even though I love
working with all these communities of
students and teachers is that it means
I'm away from my school and the students
who I have a commitment and
responsibility to and that is really
tough I miss them a lot
[Music]
keeping ad here at cherrybrook has been
a little bit of a challenge but to keep
his hand in he's still running with his
extension mathematics classes of the
morning come in grab a seat and if you
have your devices there get your devices
out I've met many students who come to
me and polite as they are will walk into
my classroom first day of the year and
they'll say look sir no offense I just
want you to know I don't do maths
there's a lot more to math than just
numbers right so I view it that kind of
student as my personal mission to turn
around all the same distance apart from
each other I've always hated maths I
don't think I had the brain for it at
all it never made sense to me and I
think not making sense just it made me
so angry
I'd like to say mathematics never came
instinctively for me which is why now I
sort of know that just because
mathematics doesn't come naturally that
doesn't mean you can't work with it and
come to an understanding of it often we
give up so I think the hard part
especially is there's so much
information even some of the most
students once they get a taste of what
it's like to be able to solve a question
they fall in love too is there anyone
who still doesn't have their name down I
call it he is I always wanted that since
childhood if you had to pick one
initially I didn't know that is had so
much interest in maths that he would
want to take [ __ ] my brother has has
made a very surprising kind of
trajectory of his own that none of us
really expected
my parents attorney and Angela they were
both born in Malaysia and they moved to
Australia largely because the education
system in Malaysia and many of the
opportunities for people growing up in
Malaysia are extremely limited
I came here when I was just about 19
don't know anybody it was quite tough
the first year especially really thought
for you because of the of the eccentric
problem we couldn't understand most of
us and definitely failing MDRC exactly
my mom did work when she was back in
Malaysia as a news reader she could
speak English fluently also Cantonese
Mandarin bahasa melayu 16 17 different
languages or dialects my parents
sacrificed a lot to come to Australia
because my mom was leaving a Korea and
my dad was leaving his family my brother
sister and I were born we were raised
here in Australia they were very very
insisted that we made English our first
language I can speak Cantonese and
Mandarin in a very cursory way I
certainly couldn't have a conversation
in Chinese which makes me a little bit
sad because I know that's part of my
history
[Music]
then wanting us to speak English came
back to them not wanting us to be
singled out as immigrants for us to be
deeply apply this culture to belong here
[Music]
hang our boys when I go on playground
duty I go out and I see these hundreds
of children running around and I watch
for the students who don't have a group
of friends or even the ones who do but I
can tell they're at the fringes I think
that growing up even though I couldn't
speak the language fluently I just
looked different and I think that that
was an easy thing for my peers to look
at and say well you know you just don't
fit in racism was something which I
definitely felt around me
they regretted that McFarlane our
customers or our language or anything
else I think there's just too many of
them when I was in primary school they
used to sing little rhymes richard mock
asians and i used to sing them then i
didn't realize what it actually meant
until later i remembered someone yelling
at me down the street ching chong
[ __ ] once upon a time and I'd been
caught I've been called [ __ ] the people
who I spent time with at school you know
sometimes they would they would beat me
up because I was little because they
could there were days when I would not
want to go to school because that was
what I knew was waiting for me my mum
she would buy me books and I really
treasured those books people in my class
who didn't like me knew how much I loved
those books sometimes they would find
them and they would steal them and I
would find them out in the playground
you know all dirty and covered in dust
all ripped up I only have one rule in my
classroom and I call it the human rule
very simple I will treat you like humans
and I expect you to treat me like a
human to one of the most important
qualities of a teacher is to be
compassionate so you got an answer but
it wasn't it's the difficult kids the
kids who don't seek out your health the
kids who are reserved yeah you're gonna
have to multiply both of them by 750 I
know that those are the kids who need
help most because I was one of those
[Music]
mom and dad were a lot of emphasis on
education they wanted us to study hard
which i think is quite coming from
migrant families out of the three of us
is went straight into James Rouge High
School which is selective James ruse is
the cream of the crop for all students
my parents thought that they had struck
gold
[Music]
they had seen that other children who'd
gone to selected high schools had come
out and become the leaders of the world
the lawyers the solicitors the the
engineers the politicians maybe we loved
him to become either a doctor or a
lawyer
these are occupations that gives you
good incomes so to speak and also sort
of more status
my brother thin said I am going to
choose education I want to be a teacher
and the air was heavy then you really
could cut the air with a knife you
really could hear a pin drop
we said we should really look at each
other and say what what is it doing what
is it they said you know why
why do you think we've come to this
country for what do you think was the
purpose of us leaving behind all our
families in our pre-established life did
you think we came here for the weather
or for the politics or for what was it
even though I I couldn't understand that
was so important to him
I just let it let it be let him do what
he wants I really wanted to do something
which I saw my skills really lined up
well with and I just the more I thought
about it the more I realize this is the
direction I want to go in a lot of the
teachers who made a very deep impact on
me who I would now say inspired me I saw
later on that they saw something in me
that I didn't see myself so Marberry
trains growing in Africa one of the
deepest memories I have is of my
agriculture teacher in year 7 mr. Brown
we were walking down to the school farm
and he turned to me and he said Edward
how are you today and I kind of paused
because I've never been asked a question
like that by an adult before and I
thought is this is this a test I just
saw teachers cared for their students
and that made a really deep impression
big part of being a teacher mr. try and
make the kids feel that they counted
and they were important I feel like
that's the thing which I gained from
here now Eddie always struck me as being
a very enthusiastic student but the last
two years of high school he went through
that all of the trauma of having his
mother very ill in his senior years I
was in year 10 when my mother was
diagnosed with lung cancer she was not a
smoker she was healthy in every way was
very fit and so Kay was a complete shock
to all of us she's not a cup of woman
who gave up easily she's struggle and
struggle I have the distinct memory of
lots of nights spent sitting beside the
bed 11 p.m. 1 a.m. 3 a.m. because she
would need someone to be able at a
moment's notice because when you can't
breathe you can't breathe to be able to
quickly act and help her Brio whatever
she needs it had to be me because there
was no one else in the family who could
do it
somehow a mum passed away is grew up
really fast it was a very difficult
period for all of us but he was youngest
and somehow feels like a rock sometimes
I get emotional when I look at the mom
yeah
[Music]
I was a emotional wreck it was him who
actually the reason for my living he
would have been comforting me and
holding my shoulders at that opinion
then you'll be right see as a young it
was a United yes sir he no sort of
comfort the father and I said by God I
wanted to be someone who could be brave
it's been a long time then yes it is and
not give over to others that burden of
having to care for me because I was a
mess um I wanted to be able to hold
things together because I saw I saw my
family falling apart around me and I
knew someone had to be strong when I
look back at it what I think it was was
his Christianity and its faith in God
that he would make mom one day again in
heaven
[Music]
it makes Eddie the person he is today
having gone through the death of his mum
I think it's made him more empathetic to
people who have an illness in 2012 I had
a student in one of my classes who was
very ill he was diagnosed and pancreatic
cancer and he was away from school for
huge chunks of time getting treatment I
still had it as a keen memory how much
of my later years in high school had
been deeply affected by a cancer and and
what that did to my education and so I
felt very personally that I should do
something about this and I came to a
realization that actually we have
technology now which can help with this
why don't I just take my phone and then
went my lesson started I just hit record
[Music]
all by other students noticed that I was
doing this and they said hey what's that
about sir and sure enough they started
to watch and they started passing the
links for the videos to their friends in
other classes and then those students
started to meet with friends from other
schools
he now has 200,000 subscribers to his
worship channel he's only getting that
traffic because students find it so
rewarding because he's such a good
explainer of mathematical complexity and
so they come back again and again and
again
and as is the case with social media the
word spreads and as the word spreads the
audience grows I don't know where he
finds the time you talk to him in East
going oh head of mass let's go to this
thing I'm going to interview panel for
health school I caught up with this
video edit this and I'm gonna start
making practice papers for you guys and
then all my kids sick can I go take him
to the doctors not going there's 24
hours in the day for you right it's not
more he really works hard at making
family time family time and work life
work life when he gets home he really
prioritizes time with our children I'm a
husband and I'm a father before I'm a
teacher and I never want to forget that
if something happens to my children or
my wife then I'm gonna be there and
they're there my first responsibility
there really could not be a better
example of a family that has the full
hand of allergic diseases he does still
say my tummy hurts
we'll do another upper endoscopy and he
and I just have bad genes so we are both
what they call a topic so we have eczema
and asthma there's such a strong genetic
component the word children really are
sitting ducks for allergic disease of
Eddie and Michelle's three children I
would say Nathan is the most severely
affected by allergic disease at four
months old I knew something was not
right he had really bad eczema all over
his skin we had to get the nurses out
every day to help us wrap his body like
a mummy when Nathan was between nine and
twelve months he started losing weight
Nathan was diagnosed with a very rare
condition called eternal philic
esophagitis this is something which even
many doctors haven't heard of the
difficulties are everyday for him eating
itself has become a really difficult
experience because when he was younger
eating was associated with an incredible
amount of discomfort and pain just to
squeeze food and drink down his
esophagus if you put him in a room with
200 other children his age he would be
shorter than 199 of them it's a concern
for me when I think about Nathan growing
up knowing that he's always going to be
little I had a little nervous for him
knowing that he'll always stand out a
little bit because of his size since
becoming a parent that's really colored
everything about the way that I approach
my work as a teacher
[Music]
if I didn't have you I think I've been
able to achieve whatever mr. chuckle
yeah Eddie's results in year 12 were
absolutely outstanding I could say
actually in 2016 I taught this boy
it's possible human beings this guy is
the Kim Kardashian of Australia
mathematics teaching as far as I'm
concerned he said he worked over the
past year it is profile has skyrocketed
and then the awards began to come his
way and more media attention he was
nominated for New South Wales local hero
which is one of the categories Ernest
for Australian of the Year the New South
Wales local hero for 2018 is
then you want it and we couldn't believe
it we were just shouting was just was
just so happy for him I'd like to
dedicate this to my mother who passed
away from lung cancer 13 years ago and
his mum not being around to see the kind
of teacher that he is is really sad she
would have been so proud of him so to
all the teachers out there and all the
schools on the same missus I'm very
proud but I was afraid that I might be
both who there was the only thing that I
I have to be a conscious so sometimes
people say oh you're so famous and he's
Tony's son
well not because of my own son he was
invited to go to Canberra for the
National Shrine of the Year awards and
we thought he's up against everyone else
in Australia and it would have been
amazing if you want but we were not
really sure Australia's local hero for
2018 is Eddy
woo sitting there in Parliament House
next to Michelle when suddenly the Prime
Minister got up and said my name and I
gradually lost sensation in the bottom
half of my body because I just thought
what what is this is this real I thought
it was one of those Oscars moments where
it was kind of like you know it's lala
land
oh no it's sorry we got the wrong
luckily this is not someone who shows a
lot of emotion he was almost in tears
tears of joy I've never really seen him
short like that but speak knowledge for
something like that was just amazing
education can radically change the
trajectory of a child's life the measure
of success in any Chinese family is how
many dentists doctors engineers or
lawyers you have in your family and we
we already have two dentists in our
family so we're considered pretty lucky
but to have an Australian local hero of
the year in our rank is just something
else entirely all together the finalists
for the 2018 global teacher prize are
Eddie wood Australia as if that wasn't
enough Bill Gates
announces that my brother is now a top
10 finalist for the global teacher prize
the global teacher prize is one of the
most prestigious that exists anywhere in
Education nominees in a hundred 73
countries around the world
[Music]
I'm in Dubai for the Global Education
and Skills forum it's a worldwide
conference of heads of state education
ministers and mixed in with them
teachers
sadly Michelle my wife and the kids who
won't be joining me it's a bit tricky
with their food allergies
pretty amazing looking at this part of
Dubai you've got these construction of
these brand-new Islands embodies just
the power of human ingenuity that
there's not land here let's just make
land ladies and gentlemen please welcome
vice president and prime minister of the
UAE and ruler of Dubai the final event
on the Sunday night will be a red carpet
gala they're going to announce who the
winner of the global teacher prize is
mathematics is a beautiful thing we're
all backing Eddie in we think is a
compelling candidate to win that prize
he wins a million dollars u.s. I think
it's 1.3 million Australian I don't even
have a concept in my brain for despite
being a numbers person for that amount
of money
this year's 10 amazing finalists there
are so many things that could be done
for education with that kind of power
and those kinds of resources
[Music]
Andrea Zafira COO
the nominated and being a member of the
top 10 for the global teacher prize is a
pretty special and amazing privilege
getting to meet all these other teachers
from around the world all of them share
the same path and believe in the power
of Education we shouldn't say Oh
someone's just a teacher we should say
you're amazing you're a teacher you
change young people's lives and you
equip them to be something they never
dreamed they could be or achieve that's
it's a miracle every single time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
No
[Music]